I have a 420 first reason that we should
believe the National Institute on Drug
Abuse has recognized a study proposing
marijuana may have a dramatic effect on
one of the most aggressive forms of
brain cancer according to the study by
st. George's University of London when
used with radiation extracts from coal
plant marijuana increased the cancer
killing effects of their radiation
the US Surgeon General claims that in
the preliminary data for certain medical
conditions and symptoms marijuana can be
helpful all right so I want to be really
clear about this one point before we
start this which is that still as we say
now every time we do a we'd video
marijuana is classified as a class-one
drug by the federal government that
means the government right now still
says the federal government still says
that it has no medicinal value that has
been disproven a bajillion times this is
just one study that it's been disproven
that it helps people with epilepsy and
seizures and cancer and AIDS and every
disease you can possibly think of people
take it to reduce stress they take it to
laugh it said well you know all those
jokes fine is this like a major major
failing of Obama III blame this on him
because even though everyone knows that
he's ok with weed why isn't he put he
has nothing to risk at this point why
doesn't he just get out there you know
he did that interview with Vice a couple
weeks ago and they asked him about and
they're like we know you're down with
weed and but why so why don't you do and
he basically was like well people have
other things to worry about which is
true but you're the president you can do
a lot of [ __ ] at once like why doesn't
he change this that's actually a great
point I mean I've never consumed in my
entire life like never this is you say
that every time we but I I've always
believed in the legalization of
marijuana because I think you can much
more you could tax the [ __ ] out of it
yes look what's happening in Colorado
right now that's money put it back into
the infrastructures that are so
underfunded and that's like it's a
win-win people want to get high maybe
you want to get some money everybody's
happy yeah it's like the weed affected
the world literally I can't quote this
exactly but I think in the first month
that Colorado legalized marijuana they
put 4 million extra tax dollars into the
public school system
you're gonna decrease the prison
population that's already a problem so
it's like there's like no downside so
what's going on so then so when the
politician sees something like this it
can shrink brain tumors I mean think
about that what that really means what
is the is this because the
pharmaceuticals are given them a lot of
money so they don't want weed I mean you
said it it would reduce the prison
population yeah prisons a business
prison this is big business yeah prisons
make so much money it's terrifying yeah
and if most of it I think most of the
nonviolent crimes have to do with drugs
yeah and most of those are probably I
don't have any statistics about me I'm
probably weed they can't lose their
population they have to keep out like I
think it's a 72 percent occupancy well
we also have we now have for-profit
private prisons which is insane we
actually have companies that have an
incentive to find people and put them in
jail for drug offenses I don't
understand why people are so afraid of
marijuana like it's there's zero deaths
reported as a result yeah of marijuana
and why is it in the same category as
other drugs like heroin yeah heroin also
LSD and ecstasy but heroin yeah like
what what the hell why well it seems to
be that it's because they they're
they're afraid that if they legalize
this and people realize that has
medicinal value it chills you out it's
top speed that people are gonna stop
popping pills and we are in a country of
people but this is all-natural you're
telling me you got a bottle I'm just
saying how soon how soon was I gonna say
how soon will we be fully legalized so
it's going down we know it's happening
like a marriage right so like we're
gonna get there and this just a callback
to our ramp all conversation earlier
where I said he's just doing what's
politically whatever like that's what I
think Obama's doing here but the part
that I don't get as I said is that he
has nothing to arrange thanks Obama
yeah like why not with a maybe then is
he waiting for the last month like he's
been a big by the way guys we
for everybody yeah what do you think
about the weed situation let us know in
the comments right now